hi guys and welcome to my channel um i'm
here with a wonderful guest who's that
guest mairo vergara and marvagara is
one of the best
english teachers in brazil if not the
best and most popular
in brazil matter isn't that isn't that
true no i think i'm a good teacher let's
put it that way not the best but a good
one being a teacher that's that's enough
it's important to find a good teacher in
life yeah
so
we just want to talk about language
learning in general but before we do can
you please introduce yourself for those
who for the few left in the world who
don't know you
and um tell me a little bit about why
you started your internet adventure as
an english teacher what what pushed you
to do that and um you know what happened
what happened in your life and what what
you're doing right now cool so uh i'm
vergara i'm from brazil uh i'm 38 i have
a wife two kids uh seven cats that's
interesting
and uh and i teach people i try to help
people um
on how to learn languages especially
english and brazil because a lot of
people want to learn english in brazil
and a lot of people have a hard time
trying to learn english in brazil but uh
before i
started my online endeavor
i used to be a translator i used to
translate uh and not an interpreter
because i think uluka was worked as an
interpreter right but there was that
actually a transl sorry
yeah i i attended a conference
interpreter i never i did work privately
as an interpreter but i never officially
worked as an interpreter but i was i
attended a conference interpreting
school in paris that's cool cool so i
was not an interpreter i was
actually a translator translating
documents from english into portuguese
it's very interesting because uh it's
kind of a standard in the industry you
translate from a foreign language into
your native language because the the
quality of the product at the end is
going to be
better you know because it's your native
language and i worked as a translator
for
four to five years i think but then i
got bored because i translating
is really good it was kind of dream of
mine because uh i was able to work from
home
uh it paid really well
but i don't know you know i really like
my one of my passions uh is language
learning not so learning language itself
but the science of language learning i
really like you know studying about how
to learn the languages and then the
different polyglots of the world like
you look and steve kaufman and many
others and what they do what they don't
do
and then i stopped translating and
started working um started teaching
people online using mainly using the
internet youtube instagram facebook you
know all the different platforms
and i started teaching people how to
learn mainly english but uh i think uh
because i talk about more about the
science of language learning uh people
can use my teachings uh even to learn
other language so yeah that's that's
what i do and
uh that's how that's how i got here
fantastic thank you so much um i was
just wondering you said something i was
just just jotting it down when you were
talking
um you said that
brazilians a lot of brazilians want to
learn english and they have a hard time
doing so can you can you explain to me
why that happens it's specifically for
brazilians because i believe that
english and brazil and portuguese is
different but not that different so what
are the main struggles and why do you
think that people struggle so much even
now that we have the internet and so
many resources yeah i think we have a
lot of private english uh teaching
schools in brazil
but i think uh
when you try to learn a language
you have to understand okay first of all
you have to understand that you learn a
language mainly outside the classroom
you you can take lessons
you know many lessons and use books and
stuff but to actually learn a language
like you need a lot of input so you need
to read a lot you need to listen a lot
you need to use the language so like if
you want to read better you have to read
more if you want to listen
develop your uh comprehension skills you
have to listen to the language you want
to speak better you have to speak more
you know communicate with people and i
always tell my students that okay you
can take these lessons you can take a
course on how to learn english you can
go to a private school you can spend a
lot of money trying to learn the
language but if you just go to the class
you know if you just you know take two
lessons one hour sessions every week
that's not going to cut it you know you
need to
study outside the classroom if you take
a look at all these students different
people trying to learn english in brazil
people that learn they maybe go twice a
week to to to lessons but besides that
they spend a lot of time like watching
tv shows watching youtube videos uh
reading the language playing video they
do a lot of stuff like they live the
language you know outside the classroom
and and that's one of the the secrets
let's put it that way uh to learn a
language but people don't like
especially in brazil teachers and
schools
they don't teach that people don't
understand that so that's uh one of
the problems but um i think that's one a
second problem is
what i like to call managing
expectations so
people when they start learning english
they think that they're gonna take a
course and i don't know in six months
they're gonna be done okay i'm gonna
take this course six months one year and
i'm gonna learn this language they think
that's learning a language learning
english like there's a beginning and
there's an ending but actually you know
that pretty well there's no ending when
it comes to language learning you know
it's like
it's a long-term endeavor a lie you're
going to learn like english i've been
learning english for quite a while
and i'm not perfect far from it
and i
i can continue to study you know
throughout all my life and i will
never you know there's no ending when it
comes to learning a language so people
have this expectation going back to
expectations to managing expectations
people have this idea i'm going to learn
this language in six months they they
then they try it
they putting a lot of time a lot a lot
of effort and at the end of six months
what happens is there's a clash
between their expectations and reality
and when there's this clash you know
your brain doesn't like it you know
because okay i wanna do this i'm gonna
you know i bought this course that
promised fluent fluency in six months i
really put in the time and uh and it
didn't work for me you know so people
start thinking oh maybe i don't have the
talent for english maybe it's not for me
and they give up so you have to manage
you have to understand that language
learning is a long-term endeavor it's
going to take a lot of time maybe a
couple years two three four i like i
like to you know between with a good
method
three to four years it's a reasonable
reasonable amount of time to to
to at least get a good graph of the
language you know at least develop the
ability to
to communicate well
uh not perfectly but well
uh in the language so yeah you have to
manage your expectations
to um
uh number one you have to understand
that you need to study outside the
classroom not only in the classroom
and i think one more thing is you have
to be consistent and a lot of people are
just just are not you know i think you
have to study every day uh it's not like
i'm gonna study twice a week and if you
study twice a week it might take you i
don't know
five six seven years to learn a language
so i think you have to do it but you
have to do it every day like at least
at least one hour a day i think and
that's hard you know if you have like a
family you have kids you work nine to
five it's it's not easy and people i
don't know exactly why but people think
like
i think not only in brazil i think
people see languages as something that
okay i'm gonna do this a couple of
months and i'm done they don't have this
it's not culturally embedded in our
brains you know ingrained that languages
really do take a lot of time to learn
you know it's like learning to
i don't know if you want to learn to
play the guitar
you're not gonna practice for six months
and you know be really good you're gonna
have the basics you know but it's gonna
take you more so languages are more
they're similar to learning a sport or
learning how to play a musical
instrument
they're not something like uh
sort of an intellectual thing that you
know it's not like learning history for
example yeah yeah yeah it's a skill it's
a skill you develop and and it's really
interesting what you said
that we have this mentality of or this
mindset most of us um they think oh just
gonna do something for a couple of
months or six months and we think it's
just gonna stick it's it's ain't going
to cut it as they say yeah i want to ask
you two questions i was taking you know
uh joining down things and questions to
to add so
you said that you were saying unjustly
so that it's important to learn every
day to be consistent
to get exposed to the language to learn
outside of the class is that what you've
done how have you learned english so
well um did you struggle at the
beginning or and and the second thing i
want to ask you which is connected is
what is it that does not work
within the the school system in brazil
i'm speaking specifically in brazil but
this is a problem that
ranges strategies all over it's it's a
global problem so these two questions
how do you learn english what do you do
and what do you think is wrong with the
school system
okay
i learned english
it's really interesting because back in
the day i used to study japanese like
back in 2004
before i knew english
i knew how to speak english so
i started studying japanese
and it was so hard like japanese was it
just
it was so hard i studied japanese for
two to three years
got to a basic to maybe intermediate
level
and kind of kind of at the same time was
learning english
but in comparison like english was just
so much easier you know it was like
english was i learned english mainly
through reading and listening just doing
that i'm the proof of the
um what is it called the the the input
hypothesis by by crashing right because
i was just reading a lot you know uh
listening a lot doing a lot of reading
websites playing video games watching tv
shows youtube videos whatever right was
just listening and reading
and after i know a couple years reading
and listening a lot
in english i kind of became i kind of
naturally became able to communicate in
the language because i was able to
understand everything that people were
saying you know so i was uh
i remember i was um the first time i
because i was afraid of speaking at the
beginning i was able to understood to
understand every
everybody but um
i have this
like i was afraid of speaking because i
thought that my pronunciation was not
good that by i would make a lot of
grammar mistakes and whatever
but i remember once uh a girl
from the philippines
i was in a room and this girl comes in
and she speaks english
and she says to me she goes like oh
they speak english i don't even remember
she talked to me in english
and i said oh
i can speak english if you can
understand me that was the exact phrase
i can speak english if you can
understand me and the reason why i said
if you can understand me was because i
was afraid that she was not going to
understand me
and she said well i can understand you
pretty well no problem and from that
moment on i realized oh my god i
understand english i can communicate i'm
kind of fluent in the language that was
back in 2000 i don't know 2006 i think
but with jeff so yeah english was kind
of reading listening and then i became
able to communicate but um
with japanese japanese was so hard was
so hard i was not able to do it i was
not i was not able like to watch tv in
japanese i was not able to read books in
japanese you know i was able to
communicate a little bit but especially
understanding was a huge problem
and then uh um
and then i started uh i don't even
remember your question what was your
question
the question was
it's so so
right we had that a lot
you know we should i should i should ask
one question at the time it's my fault
um i asked you this this question about
the english how you've learned english
and then another question about the
brazilian uh the brazilian school system
of what doesn't work but maybe you can
tell me about the brazilians and then we
can talk about japanese because i i
wanted to share some observations about
japanese myself what does it why doesn't
it work why do people like have a hard
time uh learning languages in school
okay i think it's it's it's i think
because they don't understand what was
what i was previously talking that you
need to to learn the language outside
the classroom so when you like teachers
in brazil most teachers most uh
private courses they don't they don't
teach you that that you have to spend a
lot of time outside the classroom they
say oh maybe watch a movie here and
there i'm trying to complement your
studies but it's not actually something
that they
really try to to to teach the students
and prioritize it you have to spend more
time outside the classroom and second i
think they don't realize
how you learn language most teachers
because a lot of teachers in brazil yeah
yeah i've been trying to yeah
i know i'm be honest here because
had i not
struggled with japanese
i i wouldn't know
how
the real difficulty of learning a
language because english is not that
hard to learn of course a lot of people
struggle to learn english but it's not
that
i don't i don't know i i think english
when you compare with other languages
like russian german chinese
japanese
english is not that hard
and if you if you try to learn if you
learn only english especially a lot of
people that they
i don't know they learn english because
they studied since a very young age they
learn english because they
lived in the us for 10 years you know
like my kids my i have a six-year-old
and a four-year-old both are learning
english they can speak in english
already
but uh they don't know how to learn
languages you know when they when they
grow up uh if they want to know about
the science of language learning they
have to try to learn a different
language so that's why i say it was
through japanese and struggling with
japanese that i
really learned how to learn a language
and and
and learn english and try to share
nowadays i try to share this knowledge
with people that follow me and i think
people don't realize that teachers
especially teachers don't realize that
uh don't
don't study the science of language
learners i think one of the best things
uh that teachers can do
to to to improve their their teaching
skills is to learn a different language
other than english like try to learn
french
i'm i've been learning french for about
two years so try to learn french try to
learn german russian japanese any
language and try to do it in a way like
um a lot of people they teach in a way
but they've learned in a different way
so they learn because they move to the
us but they teach like grammar stuff and
grammar-centered approaches and stuff so
try to learn a foreign language the same
way your students are learning a
language and then you're going to
struggle you're going to put yourself in
their shoes
and you're going to feel you know what
is it like to try to learn this
i don't know french language it's so
hard you know and i think that's going
to make you a better a better teacher
excellent excellent i agree with
everything you said i also believe that
um if you if you learn if you learn a
language yourself then you're going to
see inside out how it works for example
if you're an english teacher who just
knows english doesn't know other
languages you can still be an excellent
english teacher and mine was but in
general i think it adds to the whole
experience
and the expertise if you learn a
language yourself a second language
yourself
and you experiment because by
experimenting by stumbling by fault by
failing and falling you'll learn and
you're able at least to indicate the way
to pave the way so to speak and
yeah sorry with french for example uh
like two years ago uh
i wasn't able to read in french now i
can read in french so i was you know i
went through the same journey as my
students uh when it comes to reading
like listening i'm still developing my
listening skills they're kind of i think
my reading is pretty good in french uh
listening it's well it's good enough
speaking not that good because i don't
practice that much
but the thing is as i was saying you
know i uh i'm you know going through
this journey which is exactly the same
journey as my students have to go with
uh with english
makes sense um going back to japanese
because i was curious so what happened
so what what happened with japanese are
you did you go back to it or do you
speak it now or you just said no no no i
forgot at all
i forgot like everything about japanese
oh you forget because i haven't i
haven't said it in
15 years i think but back in the day i
studied japanese for
two to three years
and i went to japan for one year
i did an exchange program
and when i went to japan i thought
when you go to the country what happens
you become super fluent that didn't help
that didn't happen
but that didn't happen because i didn't
know how to do it you know i didn't know
what uh you know
i was really young i was a 20 22 i think
i'm 38 now
but it was a good lesson you know i went
to japan didn't become fluent
struggled a lot
and
and when i
then i started starting
studying and doing research on language
learning um
and when i go when i get back to brazil
and got back to brazil
i had to find a job you know after my
graduation and i had to decide between
working with japanese or english and the
market for japanese was not that great
in brazil and i decided to start
focusing on
english and english teaching
translating everything related with the
language
and i stopped studying japanese
i have plans maybe in the future to go
back you know to japanese and try to
learn it you know some do something you
know do uh like a full full circle thing
you know when i finish what i had what i
what i began like 15 years ago
but yeah i i i stopped studying that's
what happened
i it happened to me the same thing
happened to me i made a video two years
ago about saying failing to learn
japanese i have i don't think you guys
can see it but maybe you can see just a
little bit of this is my japanese spot
where i'm gonna go back
now i i know the mistakes i made so
to the approach the wrong approach that
i had towards japanese and to you guys
were listening to us if you failed
learning a language it doesn't mean that
you feel forever it means you just
stumble
and then you can just stand up and learn
again with the new expertise and then
you know what you have it's never too
late to learn a language my mother and i
we're going back to learning japanese
maybe we're all going to
move to japan and try to learn learn
japanese country approach and let's see
what happens um okay so more
specifically since you you know you've
been working as an english as an english
teacher how do you
how do you let's let's break it down i
have two three questions about
pronunciation grammar
and vocabulary so
for let's let's talk about vocabulary
what do you suggest how do what are your
tips or
let's say let's put it this way what are
the main struggles that people have with
learning and memorizing vocabulary what
do you think they they do wrong and
what's your recipe for learning and
memorizing tons of words expressions
collocations and whatnot uh that's a
person okay vocabulary
i think it's pretty simple
i think people don't read enough and
that's it
no let me let me elaborate
okay i think a vocabulary is a matter of
reading you have to read a lot
uh in the beginning you can study i
don't know how to read how how can i
start reading if i don't know how to
read you can start with short texts you
know
use bi-directional translation your
technique you know you can do anything
in the beginning short text start
reading small snippets of texts in the
language you want you want to learn
and work from that you know then you can
read i don't know greater readers i have
a bunch here you know those small books
they're really old books
yeah they're too far now but i have them
too there should be one in in
you can
you can start with short uh pieces of
text then you can move to graded readers
then you can move to books
uh or you can use uh space repetition
systems like anki you know a lot of
people like to use anki
i think it's pretty good as well but
what people don't realize is that if you
know how to use anki for example to
learn sentences by the way you never
learn individual words using space
competition systems you always learn
sentences
if you use a space repetition system to
learn sentences
at the end of the day all you're doing
is reading
because you're reviewing your sentences
it's so it's just a trick you know when
now okay you have to use this uh anki
space repetition system is pretty good i
think it's pretty good but it's just a
different it's just a trick to get
students into reading you know because
at the end of the day if you just read
every day and you do it consistently you
look up the words you don't know
you do i don't if you read every day for
30 minutes and you look up 10 or 10
words you don't need to look up every
word you don't know you look up like
five ten words a day that you know that
you don't know and you do it for one
year guess what you're going to learn to
read in english and your vocabulary is
going to increase
a lot
so vocabulary is about reading it's all
about reading now i love i love how
simply you put it in it's i i love it
it's a very good answer like how do you
people what does it mean people don't
read enough that's great genius yeah
yeah you need to read you have to read
yeah just just read every day and your
vocabulary is gonna skyrocket
i i
wholeheartedly concur and as you can see
i've like the when people ask me how do
you how do you memorize so many words i
read a ton i read like two or three
hours a day every single day i've been
reading for the last as much as
yeah as much as i write i read so i
write action or non-fiction
i read everything every i have this is
joe you have geopolitics here you have
learning how to learn the brain you
can't see it then you have do you have
novels then you have we have i have it
separated in languages and you know you
have
literature you have uh
the universe the sky i have
i have everything irritable
i read three books a day so every day i
have my reading session in the morning
for um this is more for my work so it's
neuroscience language learning
psychology because this is for you know
for for for my own academy uh that i'd
have built then i have
the um in the afternoon it's about
habits where it's about productivity and
night i relax now we're reading a novel
about um about the universe vanille the
grass i don't know if you've ever heard
of neil degrasse's uh kneel the grass
yeah i've seen a couple uh videos of him
super cool guy and and uh
so i read a lot in multiple languages
that that's how i do it but i also have
a system to
um you know space-time repetition system
i don't use anki i believe though the 80
as you said 80 90 is about massive
reading and the rest if you want to do
some repetition that's fine never works
in in isolation but it's all about
reading and i wholeheartedly concur as i
said before um let's let me ask you the
same exact question about grammar so
what happens when you say oh you have to
learn grammar from the very beginning
otherwise you can't no uh i think it
varies according to the language i think
some languages are more grammar
dependent i think uh when it comes to
ink i think english you kind of don't
need to study grammar it's pretty
starting to interact but start
interruption before i before you
continue i'm gonna ask you this
provocative question do you think
that if you don't have any grammar book
you can just expose yourself to a
language and start speaking it correctly
after two or three years even if you you
said it before you already answered but
even after let's say three years of
learning japanese listening to japanese
without any grammar explanation do you
think you're going to be speaking it be
you know
in a grammatic in a nice
grammatically correct form or you think
that there's a limit to what you can do
if you do not actually deliberately do
some grammar drills or whatever you want
to call them in order to dissect and
understand every nook and cranny of the
dramatic infrastructure of a language or
whatever you want to call it that's a
very nice question uh well i have two
answers for you
okay first it depends on the language
right i think english
maybe as with
with zero zero grammar
i would recommend a little bit of
grammar just a little bit of grammar
when it comes to okay
if it's like now let's let's
you don't need to go into japanese let's
french
french you need a little bit more
not that much more you know but a little
bit more with verb conjugations and a
lot of stuff you know there's a the
masculine feminine stuff it's it's you
need a little bit more grammar so
and
as theoretically
if you just expose yourself
theoretically if you just expose
yourself to the language for
12 hours a day
for
eight years maybe you can do it
but that's in theory right because
nobody's gonna expose expose themselves
12 hours a day for 10 years to the
language so when it comes to grammar um
i think you of course you should read
you should listen you should input as
much as possible it's the single most
important important factor when you're
learning a language
uh
and you just do a little bit of grammar
you know on the side such a little bit
maybe once a week twice a week you know
just because i think as you expose
yourself to the language you're going to
acquire
a lot of that language but they're going
to be some i like to call it some some
gaps in your knowledge
you know some holes and you stood a
little bit of grammar just to cover this
small holes you know maybe you can
communicate in french but you cannot
conjugate the verbs properly so you
start a little bit of verb conjugation
maybe in english you don't understand
the i don't know the present perfect you
know and the usage of the auxiliary
verbs and stuff and then you study a
little bit but it's just a little bit
you can't be like grammar a
grammar-centered approach as a lot of
teachers in schools do especially here
in brazil it's like lesson one the verb
to be lesson two the simple present
lesson three the past simple whatever uh
no no you cannot uh grammar is just a
compliment some sort of uh an auxiliary
thing that you do to
to to
fill those those holes
that uh you're well said very well said
uh i agree
i agree i have my own system i believe
that um as you said you you were
pointing to the fact that um you
had a hard time in japanese and not such
a hard time with english i would say it
depends on the language in the sense
that i would have a
let's say
um
a massive input approach for languages
that are similar and i believe by
osmosis or just by exposure to language
is really similar like catelyn spanish
portuguese i would not be i would not
need grammar explanations but the more
distant the language is especially at
the beginning i believe the grammar
explanations can be very helpful because
some languages have completely different
features that are totally alien to us
and unless someone explains that to us
and with very simple explanations which
i by the way i believe is a huge
advantage we adults have over kids we
have
someone explaining in our own native
language the idiosyncrasies of another
language so i my in my own in my own way
of seeing things i do this
bi-directional translation at the
beginning especially for languages it i
apply to all languages but because i
like it but i recognize that for some
languages like very similar languages i
can just get into it dive into it and
just learn while it's extremely
beneficial for languages that are
distant like i've i've used it for
german russian chinese it works really
well because by translating back and
forth with the complement the com the
you know the complementary aid of
grammar explanations it helps you
get a very solid grasp of the language
at the very beginning which helps
facilitate the acquisition even the
implicit acquisition of of
a language this is called a weak
interface model i don't know if you ever
heard of that i'm going to put in the
description box a very cool video of a
guy who's uh he's a linguist he's a
japanese linguist that talks about that
he's made a wonderful wonderful
presentation and he explains the crash
and model uh he considers the crashing
model a little bit outdated and he
thinks that i am more leaning towards
this
kind of weak interface model i know
these are like you know vague terms
right now but if you take a look at the
uh if you watch the
interface model right
you know that the name well he talks
about the weak interface model he talks
about crashing's model the input
overview of all the linguistic models
that are currently you know competing
with one another nowadays i'm gonna send
you the link and i'm gonna put it
in the description box for for our uh
lovely viewers uh to use
um but in general yes i believe that
you know you can you can actually use
different approaches depending on the
language we have to be flexible um
okay good go ahead go ahead
no i was going as i was going to say
that i i think a lot of people
misunderstand crashing i think they i
agree i agree because i think people
think oh you're going to listen a lot
and naturally going to speak and what no
it's just that
if you
analyze any person that becomes fluent
in a foreign language there's one single
thing that's common among all of you
know you me anyone that learned a
foreign language and it it is the input
you know you can't achieve fluent it's
not possible to become fluent you're not
gonna find a person that's fluent in
russian french english whatever that
hasn't done like thousands of hours of
input there's no logo i just you know i
haven't done i haven't read i haven't
listened i just i don't
spoke the language and and it happened
no it's present in every person that is
fluent in a language it's the only i
okay you'll go ahead sorry no sorry
sorry i wanted to add that it's not just
input it's comprehensible compelling
that he says and the second thing i
wanted to say is that the reason why
people misunderstand crash and i believe
i've been been watching his videos
recently i also have a couple of books i
i think he's he hits a nail on the head
not on everything i don't agree on
everything i'll make a video about that
but i agree with
ninety percent of what he says um but i
believe that um you know when he talks
about inputs this doesn't mean that you
don't have to speak you speak later once
at the input and he also talks about
anxiety or
you know
even cultural reasons that keep they
create kind of a filter that keeps
people from speaking but that's another
matter so
input first then when speaking when he
talks about speaking that's a that's a
different matter but it's connected with
the input so i agree with you that he
gets
but i would say that not even i i i
i don't think it should be like input
first
you can input like you you need input
you know you can speak from day one can
you yes if you want to speak from day
one i don't like to do it i like to
delay it but so you can
do only input for two years and then
speak or you can do input from day one
and speaking from day one but you
the input you know
have you know you need the input without
input there's no learning and i think
that's what people don't understand
about the
model
i agreed 100
um a question about
accent slash pronunciation we've talked
about it at length during your
your interview but i wanted to
to know what do you think the struggles
are what do you think so few people can
get a native like accent or even a good
pronunciation of that and um what are
the current struggles that people have
the right that do they do things wrong
and how do you help them sorry there's a
lot of yeah i think i know
pronunciation uh i used to i i i still
think my pronunciation sucks but uh i
used to be much worse no i i was really
bad at pronunciation because when i
learned english it was just listening
reading without doing any grammar
studies without doing any uh
pronunciation studies so i used to
mispronounce a lot of things
then i started maybe five years ago i
don't know i started studying and
learning about pronunciation
and i found out that it's not that hard
you know to learn let me give you a a
concrete example i used to say instead
of pronunciation you used to say uh
pronunciation
then i learned oh it's not pronunciation
it's a pronunciation then i i learned i
listened i practiced okay it's
pronunciation pronunciation then i
started learning you know that about the
i learned about the the ipa the
international informatic alphabet i
think you don't use the ipa to
remember yeah but i think
it doesn't matter you know i learned
about the sounds of the language you
know how to properly pronounce words
like the th sound gives a lot of
problems to brazilians you know because
we don't have the th sound uh
in portuguese so words like thank you
especially at the end of words like both
with or when you have the s after the th
you have like six
sixths it's hard to pronounce but if you
learn the sounds you listen to the
sounds and you practice
uh it's not that hard because i'm not
talking about having a perfect accent
you know
you know pronunciation is all about how
to pronounce
uh the sounds of given uh certain words
or the words of the language properly
you don't need to sound like an american
you don't need to have an american
accent like my uh english is like
brazilian
english you know i have my brazilian
accent
but i kind of know how to pronounce the
words properly
and when i teach my students i just it's
it's similar to grammar you know you
just study a little bit and learn sound
by sound word by word how to pronounce
them and you practice and one thing that
happens with pronunciation
is that
even more important than learning how to
pronounce the words is that
pronunciation in my opinion i don't know
if you agree with that or not but it
boosts your confidence
when speaking the language and it's and
when you speak in the language it's all
about confidence now if you know how to
pronounce a word you're gonna if you
practiced you know you're gonna
pronounce it you know that you
you know i was as i was we're talking uh
back in the day i was afraid of speaking
the language because i was afraid of
making mistakes or of mispronouncing
words
and nowadays nowadays i'm a little bit
better and i have more confidence and um
i try to teach the same to to to my
students you know work on your
pronunciation one word at a time
and
you're gonna develop your confidence and
um
soon you're going to start speaking
i i like it i like the concept of
confidence and pronunciation i i believe
that pronunciation and confidence they
are
entangled you know they're intertwined
and tangled and i believe you know
sometimes
and disco is also for the language in
general when we're not you know we're a
little bit self-conscious we walk into a
conversation thinking oh my god
everybody's going to look at me every
day everybody is going to judge me that
kind of thinking
it kind of gets in the way of actually
producing language the correct way we
all have it because we're human beings
we're scared of the unknown we're scared
of using a new thing in different
situations with different people so it's
totally understandable but i agree 100
with you that if we kind of break this
uh this barrier then we get more and
more confidence i don't know has that
ever happened to you but to me i've been
scared of multiple situations then once
i faced them be it in a foreign language
i wasn't scared of this interview
you're scared
yeah yeah i to be i i live in brazil i
don't speak english that often i think
uh
maybe once a year i have the opportunity
to have a conversation in english so i'm
the proof i'm kind of the proof of the
hype uh input hypothesis because it's
really rare for me to have a
conversation in english and still
after like years without speaking the
language i'm still able to sit down and
have an interview it's it's pretty i
think you're doing fantastically well
you speak really well i think you have a
great accent um
so
um
matt it's been it's been wonderful
talking to you it was a pleasure thank
you very much thank you
you're most welcome uh you you can find
me on youtube uh mario vergara uh it's a
m-m-a-i-r-o
and vergara it's a v-e-r-g-a-r-a
and uh yeah youtube my vergara uh if you
type on google my very guide you're
gonna find my instagram or facebook but
nowadays it's more about uh youtube yeah
you got a lot of people following you so
yeah a huge fan keep keep shining yeah
thank you so much
keep shining a light on language
learning because i think the world needs
more people talking about you know how
to learn languages because i i do
believe i'm very honored um to be able
to do this job because you can show
people how they can develop improve
their own world and i think you're also
doing something similar so that's that's
fantastic thank you so much guys for
watching thank you everybody from rome
and from modern world in brazil you are
i live in london
in brazil okay
and from rome and talk to you very soon
bye-bye guys bye-bye